[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
where today
we are currently off the record oh it's
so serious and it's a hot seat with
chips wow i've never been this before
oh dude you're the house of dragons dude
oh my gosh i can't talk this off we
always have to start it off cold and
then up the ante and bar hit it off okay
i like aunties are you ready let's get
it
there's a cold question okay okay ready
yeah
if yeah you took a slug okay
and then you put it
in a shell uh-huh
is it a snail
or a hermit slug
hermit slug for sure yeah no no snail
appropriation
um
because
because uh they're not meant to have
shells he's just like he's jealous of
the snails you know what i'm saying he's
just like a cold slug hmm you know i
don't know what you said you know what
i'm saying dog that's a good answer
that's a good answer that's a really
good answer yeah he put thoughts with
him yeah i don't even understand what he
said but bart was bart was in the marvel
cinematic universe who would he be
um asian hulk
there it is
there is actually a chill
i'm going to be that shang
in any marvel movie i'll play anybody
dude i'll play [ __ ] wasp boy whatever
you know
well if they give him more lines he can
say more [ __ ] last night
that's true that's very
good
you could be beast too if you want to
talk more because he's smart oh yeah
i like him yeah this
if you were a marvel cinematic universe
superhero anti-hero villain bystander
who would you be damn who would i be
like an existing marvel character right
or even one that you're a fan of growing
up oh man so i was a big x-men fan that
was like my [ __ ] growing up i bought all
the comics and [ __ ]
um
man
uh jubilee
wow
racial undertones
i didn't know jubilee was asian until
like way later yeah juba lee
yeah dawg you ain't know no i didn't
know him it's like jubilation jubilation
lee yeah
yeah um [ __ ] i mean i guess uh
damn who would i be
um wow you really put me on the spot i
can't handle this hot seat dude you
can't even they're about to give you a
roll right now and you're [ __ ] it up
they're [ __ ] up magic we want you in
the movie who do you want to be
no i don't even know get me out of this
building
um damn i would probably be um
ty gambit
thai
okay
yeah yeah and i'm throwing mahjong
[Laughter]
farther pieces that's tight i've been
wanting to do this as an asian avengers
okay yeah
okay
so we got the we got the man we got the
gambit with the mahjong yeah i've been
to new orleans
okay we gotta have the chinese cook
that's his his power is to squat and
smoke cigarettes but when he blows it
out it's like the smoke is like crazy
yeah it's so crazy that like it blinds
people and gives them secondhand why
somebody didn't pick this movie up
already dude the smokey blows yeah let
me tell you
[Laughter]
yeah let's do it yeah there's an asian
auntie
she likes nazis and she jacks you off i
heard
massage breaks all your bones and
injects you off until you're dehydrated
death by dehydration
all right so when was the uh last time
i'm just going on a whim here you were
super pissed off
oh
wow uh last time i was super pissed i
never see this guy that's what i'm
saying where you lost control a little
bit do you ever lose control i don't
lose control dawg damn
it takes a lot to really piss me off
um even with chia around
let me think let me see
don't fall for it i'm really trying to
watch jk it's cool because we got it you
know she doesn't we got into she doesn't
like bart's voice
um
i'm trying to think ah
there was something recent where i got
mad oh you know what oh and this is not
even like an entertaining answer this
was like a real like a road trip
like argument you know i'm saying and we
were driving somewhere
and
and she just like
she was also frustrated and we got into
a fight where she was like
what did she say she was like because
you're not paying attention you're
making stupid decisions and i was like
hey
uh you know what when you get frustrated
don't like the way you talk to me
that's you're angry he sets a boundary
we had like a real conversation we had i
was like i had a tough conversation the
first time i actually like went a long
time where i really was just like hey
you know what when you when like i got
real you know what i'm saying because a
lot of times i feel like when i get
frustrated i do more of a uh
uh
like i'm joking but i'm also you can
tell i'm [ __ ] irritated and um so
you're just trying to like brush it off
till you could calm down yeah very like
what's the word like um
passive aggressive you know and so it
takes a lot for me to actually be like
hey yo i'm [ __ ] angry right now well
i'm bothered you feel me um but as far
as like angry lose control i don't
really do that though how are you so
self-aware where like you can go
i recognize that
that rubbed me the wrong way instead of
just like
sucking the window or something because
i feel i always feel like that's sucking
the windows always be like that's silly
you know i'm almost like what am i going
to suck a window for this is this it's
just a reaction right it's just like a
reaction and the silliness comes in
afterwards and then afterwards i'm like
oh [ __ ] i wasn't dead
to the whole wall flies
no dude i'm just you know when you get
mad you like soccer steering wheel or
something
dude i just don't like
feeling mad bro you know what i'm saying
i don't like it either but i just can't
control it
who likes it right but i always get to a
point where
um i would just rather not like i don't
i don't like the way i feel like in all
of that so i really try to keep it
together and so when when i get to that
point i'm like i really try to just keep
it together you feel me i've never been
like a wall puncher oh that type of [ __ ]
you have something to let that [ __ ] out
though or does that like pile up and
then one day
not really dog i mean you know yeah i
like um i like kill squirrels and [ __ ]
in the pond
that's my release but
yeah that's regular we got too many
squirrels what's the most pissed off
you've been in your entire life then
like what's the v moment v like oh my
god i'm so [ __ ] pissed i'll never
want to be like that again i never met
anybody so kind of all right look
immediately when you say that to me
um i remember and this is one of the big
reasons that me and my ex just didn't go
well together because i felt like she
brought out a part of me that i didn't
like you feel me and she was the only
girl
where i did want to [ __ ] punch walls
and [ __ ]
yeah i hated
with feeling that way yeah and she was
the only person that like
it was even looking back on it so like
it feels so embarrassing right where you
like she we were arguing in a parking
lot and she walked away from me and i'm
like and i'm like in her face and doing
that type of [ __ ] i'm like don't walk
away from me yeah yeah and like i hate
that you know what i'm saying i hate
like making a scene like that just
losing control like you're like i can't
believe i'm that guy yeah yeah
because you see that and you're just
like ah
i'm glad i got my [ __ ] under control and
then you do it yourself and you're like
[ __ ] i don't want to be this person dude
yeah so that's the
era this is the yeah yeah yeah a long
time ago and so that was the most pissed
off you've been was just
that i can think of off top yeah where i
really just like lost control i guess
you never screamed at someone and say
shut the [ __ ] up and choke them
the squirrels
shut the [ __ ] up
all right you don't have to say any
names or anything like that but uh is
there someone or some company that you
worked for or worked with in the past
that you like [ __ ] never want to work
with them again man there was this
[ __ ] brand deal company it was it was
uh you could say the name too i don't
even remember the name it was like some
jewelry company i forget
but you know like
when we do brand deals like it's great
like having just really easy laid back
flowing experience is the best right
like i want to [ __ ] with these people
again they like working with me but it
was just one of these where it was like
they were so being so annoying and
particular like i would send a draft
they'd be like actually can we get more
of a close-up on this i'm like alright
whatever whatever i do it's so nice and
then oh dog i know i'm too nice
sometimes and then um we kept going back
before they step they kept having their
just most annoying notes and i'm like
for what y'all are paying bro this isn't
worth it and i was i told my middle man
i was like dog tell these people
[ __ ] their money i don't want i they're
really annoying you know what i'm saying
i was like i don't want to do this
anymore i was ready to be like yo [ __ ]
this little [ __ ] or however what
much they're sending me he was like
let's just try and make his work he's
trying to make this workout like ah fine
but i hated it
today's video is brought to you by
draftkings football fans the first
sunday of nfl season is here and
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl is giving new
customers a can't miss offer to
celebrate the return of the nfl season
right now new customers can bet just
five dollars and get two hundred dollars
and free bets instantly and as an added
bonus for week one everyone can
experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion it's simple bet on a
nfl team to win if your team leads by 10
at any point during the game you get
paid instantly even if your team loses
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use the promo code off the
record to get 200 and free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet this sunday that's called off the
record only at draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
detail
what does they rhyme with
that's so nice bobbins brothers um like
schmithany's not just way
the gliers
[Laughter]
all right so
we've been on youtube extremely long i
think you've been on longer than us
like by a year or so okay yeah it's been
like
16 plus years or some [ __ ] right years
all right
so like
you keep doing new [ __ ] and like
doing different things right
is there [ __ ] where you're just like man
i still haven't done this yet and then
you want to create more or are you more
like man i'm tired of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm done nah
to be honest like i kind of feel like
i've been grinding all these years to
finally get to a place where i want to
do the [ __ ] i really want to do so you
haven't been doing [ __ ] you really
wanted to do no because i mean like
you've all been alive it's all it's not
been a lie bro it's been a journey
because like i've been um
i mean originally you know i got on
youtube because i wanted to be in tv and
movies and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
so it's like now i feel like after
10 plus years of grinding
and you know and and the diversity push
in hollywood people are finally being
like let's hear some diverse stories
let's cast some diverse [ __ ] you know
now i got more auditions this past year
than i have in my whole [ __ ] 16 years
of trying to get into this [ __ ] you know
so i feel like now
the industry is finally actually open to
it right so i'm like and now after after
building this following for so long i
kind of have a little leverage to get my
foot in the door right where it's like
okay i have some numbers um they've seen
me do
tv content i've done some scripted
content where i might be able to be like
hey i wrote this movie
what's good you know what i'm saying so
that like i'm trying to write this
[ __ ] movie and um
um is it about a thai
lovers
it's kind of a tie lover i got some
weird [ __ ] i want to do but before i do
the weird [ __ ] i'm trying to write just
like a stupid uh buddy movie for me and
david you know it's just like a little
soft easy cell [ __ ] you know yeah so
that's what i'm trying to do right now
and i feel like you know i it's a good
time to try and do that you know
something's tight i'm trying to get it
done doug it's hard bro y'all have
written movies that's just hard we wrote
five yeah
yeah that's we just wrote it though
that's more than me dog
hey but it's you by yourself we had a
team of like four like we just sat there
and [ __ ] cranked it out you know and
i have people like hey let me know if
you need help but i really just in my
own i really want to write this [ __ ]
myself yeah it's a different if it's
different because like even if they
they're good it morphs into a different
organism because everyone's idea comes
together
yeah if you want to write your own [ __ ]
you got to be it by itself i'm trying
man veda
giving you advice that's the hard [ __ ]
too dog with a baby
bruh cause like i need to just sit down
and write but then it's like it's hard
to do that when you got a little baby
running around so the only time i really
have to write is when she's asleep and
after she goes to sleep the [ __ ]
house is a mess so i need to clean the
house and then you know answer emails
and then i sit down and write and i'm
like
that's right the last time yo look
remember when we did that [ __ ] chili
channel challenge where like it was like
okay write this movie or else we got to
take up yeah
i'm on the same [ __ ] dog i ain't doing
[ __ ] since then i'm on the same 10 pages
i'm actually less off because i looked
at the 10 pages i wrote was like nah we
switching it up so i'm like less than
when we started
because you started deleting pages yeah
cause i was like i was like nah this
just starts off too serious i gotta flip
it damn yeah so now that you've been
living the dad
is there uh moments before the dad life
were like man i missed
these days when it was like this like
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
i mean i you know whenever i want the
moments you miss i mean we've been off
the [ __ ] [ __ ] for a long long long time
oh that's right that's right but i i
just had this conversation recently in a
video with you because um
i i asked her
uh
how much no she asked me on a scale of
1-10 how much do you miss our lives
before veda right and
and i was like honestly like i ate and
not that um that means i don't love veda
life because i do i love being a dad i
love everything about it
but i can still like look back on my
previous life and be like
man that [ __ ] was great right um
especially since we had a good
you know pandemic by ourselves just
[ __ ] chilling watching movies just
enjoying each other eating watching
movies like that's my [ __ ] just eating
and watching movies right so we had a
whole year
uh and some change of just doing that
and uh and i do miss like going out to
new restaurants trying new food sitting
in movie theaters because i you know
i've been off the club [ __ ] i just like
watching movies right so it's like that
those two things are the two things we
just don't do at all anymore going to
theaters
sitting in restaurants you feel me just
made a cries
because vader's just little
pain in the ass [ __ ] eating with the
kid different different experience huh
yeah yeah so even like i remember you
know when i was like yelling at y'all
for not having watched like endgame yet
i was like bro it's been six months but
you like we have a child that's like
he's grown but now i'm like oh i get it
because i haven't just i rarely go to
theaters now so that would be something
like i i miss you know yeah yeah so as a
as a uh father's right what would your
advice be to us future fathers that want
to abandon our kids
so we don't have to deal with this [ __ ]
then you gotta go fast before they
recognize you dog
it's gonna be sad when they start loving
you and you bounce bounce immediately
accurate at that point
they know who you are
um
but yeah just get out quick dog so so
you you
so you miss that life but do you try to
kind of get it or meet in the middle or
hire a babysitter for the day okay so
so two things right so chia when i asked
her that question she was like she's
like honestly maybe like a three because
she's so
wrapped up in mommy life she doesn't
even think about that [ __ ] right but she
understands how much i miss it so um i
always complain to her that she's a
really difficult person
i always tell her like look man if we're
not sitting in a theater you're not
watching this [ __ ] for real you don't
say you feel me so why she's on her
phone or whatever on her phone she's
distracted she's like i don't have a no
phone rule no it don't
work complain
like i complain her so much that like
when we watch a show she understands how
much that's important to me maybe she
got 80d maybe but she'll try and focus
with me oh so that's why you like the
theater environment because it feels
it's forcing her to watch she also like
you know she feels like oh it's a movie
i can or it's a show i can just listen
to but i'm like i'm sitting here like
you missing a cinematographer yeah
missing everything nuances
or just asking plot questions like 30
minutes long no that's that guy she
don't give a [ __ ]
i'm like and i want her to give a [ __ ] i
wish she asked me about it
i don't watch it like did you see that
that was all one shot girl yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it had cuts in her eyes exactly right
it's the engagement so you're like what
do you call it the quality time yeah
that's that's your love language it's in
there so you know high quality time shut
up and just watch i'm not talking about
just watching between you and chia are
there any
approaches or ways in raising your
guys's daughter that you differ
oh
that's a good one
um because most mommies and daddies
don't agree 100
yeah um let me i'm trying to think if
we've ever
um
you know what i think because we're both
new or you know we're both like trying
to navigate it there are times where
um i think she'll forget
that like oh [ __ ]
well she's just so tired that like you
know oh [ __ ] the baby watching a lot of
tv i'm like all right let's turn the tv
off let's go play some games or
something right like like [ __ ] like that
but it's never been anything that we
like butt heads about for the most part
we kind of agree on [ __ ] but there has
been um
[ __ ] wasn't gonna say it was a good one
for you guys too
uh
oh no oh i was gonna say
i
have an uber driver really said
something to me the other day that
really kind of like stuck with me right
because
you know being at my first
child and she's my daughter i'm very
like
it's hard to scold her or discipline her
um because you know it's like a little
girl right so i've been trying to like
not
not baby her to not not princess her too
much right and and from just dating very
um
uh princess entitled girls in the past
i'm like i don't want my girl to turn
out like this but it's always kind of
like oh it's very casual i'm like oh i
don't want her to turn out to be a
princess right but this uber driver was
like man you got that
you got that baby girl she's probably
has you wrapped around her finger i'm
like yeah he's like look man don't make
the mistake
of
um you know being like treating her too
much of a princess he's like because
what that'll do it'll set her up for
heartache in her life and i was like oh
[ __ ] no one's ever said it like that
before and i immediately thought of all
the really like
super entitled
girls in my life who got everything they
want and how they're in relationships
now and they refuse to realize what
their issues are and so they're
constantly like heartbroken
lonely because it's never their fault
it's never their fault and i was like
whoa he's right so they don't know how
to grow from it yeah you gotta tell
david everything's her fault yeah yeah i
gotta be like
get off instagram this is yeah because
she's always not just my honor
did you still rate that guy four stars
oh no well his car stank so i gave him
advice for you wash your car
nah that's a good dude yeah good music
too surprisingly
damn man
well that's cool i just can't believe
you're still i just can't believe both
of you guys are still dads
and that weird deal what do you think is
gonna happen
they're gonna get typhoid no i feel like
it's it's i feel like it's chia's
daughter and jio's son
because it's just i don't know man
insults a man without insulting him
yeah no i mean
i feel like even even uh the homies like
man can't believe i can't believe you
got a you got a whole daughter you know
what i'm saying but it's different i
think everybody everybody in my life
realizes that's just different i don't
even go out ever anymore unless there's
a
i used to go out a lot i was out i was
out and about you know i liked
socializing i mean you know i wasn't a
party boy i feel like i know the
importance of uh the [ __ ]
networking aspect of being that's why
you're hella successful dude
you know man i'm just
i just know how to fake it dawg
but you seem like you came up with a lot
of your close friends so that's pretty
that's cool
yeah for sure
um we're gonna end it with a little bit
harder question okay
um
if there's one thing
that you can improve about chia what
would it be
yo
and you don't even have to tell her you
just would think it and then it just
becomes
watch this video or anything like that
she won't
um
man look i i tell her all the time right
one of our biggest issues
is that
she
doesn't realize the way she says things
sometimes like a [ __ ]
like a not pleasurable old [ __ ]
oh she's mean
she's just you know oh
she's just
she doesn't her her approach isn't
always the greatest her delivery isn't
the greatest so i'm like hey man look uh
sometimes the way you talk to me uh it's
so i feel a little it's a little
condescending you feel me i'm not stupid
all right i'm not a stupid boy i'm a
grown ass man um and i'm like i didn't
appreciate that i just don't talk to me
like i'm dumb
and she's been working on me right now
i forgot what we're talking about we
were like sending voice memos back and
forth and then uh tim was telling me
something and in the background i heard
she go no we're not moving to vegas bar
this full part
recruiting dude this fool is like he's
like a secret real estate in vegas or
some [ __ ] cause i'll literally be like
hey man the weather looks nice in vegas
and he'll send me eight voice notes
about why
why it's great to live
he does that to everybody dude
that's so good
he works for the tourism yeah bro i'm
like i don't want to buy a house from
ant dog i'm good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you